so we've got a situation here with a
farmer or child isn't trapped in a grain
bin
we've got plastic coffers here and we'll
be placing these on each side of the
victim these are actually going to
protect the victim from the corn to get
the corn from collapsing in on
[Music]
we can also work on trying to pull him
out with a couple people ready here we
go one two three okay he's got himself
with us being the only ones with this
system within quite a long range it may
take us a while to get where we need to
go so it may be more of a recovery then
it will be of a rescue but we always
hope that we can
[Music]
Rising Sun and pretty quiet town it's
one of those places where you can ride
your bicycles room spent a lot of time
playing basketball on the basketball
forwards like quite a few friends when I
wasn't with friends I was on the farm
working it was like the coolest thing to
do is to come to the forum and work but
now it's all mechanized and it's kind of
fewer people bigger machines
[Music]
my first job was in seventh grade
felt like a real life hit me already and
I've matured a lot faster than I see
others as a kid I took care of the
calves put out Hey
just erased the back and stripped a lot
back remember as a kid sitting in the
strip and in all night and all day ready
to get out of there that kind of set me
up to doing a lot more taking a lot more
responsibilities
I try to stay out of the gossip in the
drum and all that I want to do myself I
try to make friends with everybody you
know hey how you doing hope you have a
good day I think that's where I kind of
meet standards is everybody obviously
with all the wet work that we're kind of
limited to billboard so we'll work just
on maintenance stuff and getting things
caught up that mean we get extra days
off we might get off and half-hourly
we've we're kids dad was so busy we
didn't really see him very much so we
wrote around my grandfather and he blows
drive in the fields so we were driving
tractors and trucks when we were like
seven or eight and then once we started
getting a little older we slowly kind of
worked into adult life on the farm
you put in all the sweat and tears get
them in the ground they grow in a sense
like a grown kid
[Music]
the farm chords out now to get to this
size that took five generations to know
all the work and sweat and blood that
was place more than just a farm it's
just home
[Music]
I got travel about transportation time
you know I'm starting to add up these
costs and sometimes we get in a hurry
you know last year we lost 25 people due
to a farming accident so if I use this
bin as the example anyone come up here
give me anything you know the grain bins
about half full all right we got a guy
here and usually there's a little noise
going on right right what happens right
off the bat he's yelling stop stop stop
stop stop you can't hear have we lost a
guy already can we find him and you know
you take one of these great big grain
bins how am I gonna scoop him out think
about we don't want to lose anybody
right we don't want lose people you know
in life there's always rules and we
don't always like them but it is for
everybody's best interest because it's
not gonna happen to me
[Music]
it's actually happened just recently the
gentleman he's probably mid-50s
he was in a band it was down to the
bottom in December but it was piled
really high on the edge well he was
trying to dig it and pull the grain down
and came down on him this book got
caught in the auger so he was stuck
there it's so loud you know you can't
yell really
and he wouldn't you know it's just one
of those things it's just like being
underwater since he took a breath that
was pretty much it I think anytime
something like that happens is this
shark for the community like it's kind
of a wake-up call and it's a reminder
you know what we're doing is not
entirely safe nine-one-one which
emergency no and okay I'll take you me
right my god we need everything great
relax
k12 blades to cut into the bend we need
approximately 12 semis
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I started Danish learning support new
volume we've been dating for three
months now I mean I'm I'm really happy
to see big growth off of our house and
it's laying one of these days you know
start building family I mean I'm right
on the edge of the real one
I stripped the headline around I didn't
have a dome lights up with the LEDs in
school here got lucky I plan on keep
farming you know kind of make it bigger
if I can something I'm good at and I
don't want to you know going where my
goal would be is if I had a child that
wanted to come back and farm then I
would be able to do that financially for
me was that same thing with he loves
tractors and hoorah can we go by he's
like ride ride you know he wants to go
the farm so it's a neat industry
involved in because you can be with your
family it's still working
[Music]
as far as dangerous jobs the grain bin
it's a deal
because I mean you can be gone in an
instant and it's not just me it's my
wife
Abbadon you know it's the rebels force
institute so if I go their whole way of
life is good
[Music]
it's always in the back of your head is
it worth it getting inspected
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]